This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of
Hello everybody. Let's go ahead and
wait. What? Wake up the waiting group.
No, let's just let them in as they are
already awake. Hello. Hello. Welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. My name is
Becca Dukes. And if you're live with us
in the live Zoom, make sure that you
have that chat open. We don't have
Marilyn today, but we're still going to
have some notes going in there. And if
you have questions, go ahead and put
your questions in the chat as well. For
those of you who are watching us out on
any of the different platforms,
uh, make sure that you like and share,
send us some love and subscribe to our
channel. Also,
type in there where you are joining us
from. We want to know.
So, this program is for educational
purposes only. We do have to say this.
We don't don't want the FDA to come down
on us and say that we're doing anything
we're not supposed to do. So,
I'm super excited though because we have
a lot of animal lovers
in our audience and just around the
world. And I can't think of anybody
better.
Oh, no. There's Dr. Wallik and then
there's Dr. Judy.
So, I'm super excited to have Dr. Judy
with us today because we're going to be
stepping into a fascinating conversation
that begins with the world of horses,
but may challenge how we think about
human health as well. So, joining us
today, we do have Dr. Judy Reynolds,
PhD. She's an educator. She's a
researcher. She's a nutrition expert and
someone who has spent years connecting
dots between science, feeding
strategies, and whole body function. Dr.
Reynolds is a graduate of Texas&M and
has taught science at the college level,
helping students understand complex
biological systems in practical and
meaningful ways. Her work has also
included formulating horse feeds and
developing feeding and nutrition pro
programs, including working with ADN,
giving her a unique perspective at at
the intersection of research, nutrition,
and realworld application. Well, today
she's going to be sharing some of her
very own research into hyper calmic
periodic paralysis or HPP, a condition
seen in horses that can appear almost
mysterious in nature where muscle
function changes, episodes occur
unexpectedly,
and severe cases can be
life-threatening.
Dr. Reynolds is also going to explore
the human side of this conversation,
looking at nutritional deficiencies
and everything that comes with it and
questions around how nutrition may
influence
function and the resiliency
of the body. So, Dr. Judy, thank you so
much for joining us today. I am super
excited is this is some of your very own
research hands-on in the moment that you
have done and I am excited to be able to
share it with with our whole audience
around the world and I'm especially
excited when you get to how it relates
to some things that go on in the human
world too. So, thank you so much Um, I
know you've got an amazing presentation
put together, so I'm just going to turn
it over to you if that's okay.
>> That is awesome, Becca. Thank you so
much for the invitation. I love being
here and this is a special one for me
because like you said, this is my
research. When you do a PhD, which is,
you know, basically that means you're
studying, but you also have to do
research and you have to defend your
research and and all that. Um just a
just a quick comment on who gets called
a doctor and who basically doesn't get
called a doctor out there in the world.
So two main groups of people we are
officially
called doctor. In other words, you say
doctor and then your name. Number one,
the medical doctors which we know MD
that those are medical doctors. And then
there are PhDs. That's called a doctor
of philosophy. And PhDs do two main
things. They do research and they
educate people, but they're also called
a doctor because they had to go through
a research project. They had to defend
it. Not just do things that you can do
with learning, taking courses, things
like a a master's degree and things like
that, you can do that way. The other
kinds of people that basically have a
doctorate would be your lawyers. They're
a JD, a jurist doctorate, but they don't
call themselves doctors. And then there
are people like EDDDs, education
doctors. In other words, if you're in
education, say you teach high school or
something, and you if you keep teaching
for years, every year you have to get
continuing education credits. And if
you're smart, you're going to group
those. And eventually, if you're a
teacher, you'll you will get a master's
degree. as a teacher, you'll get a
master of education. And then if you
keep doing that for a long period of
time, you can get a master or a a doctor
of education, which is an EDDD.
And those people do not are not supposed
to call themselves doctor. They're
they're a doctor of education, but um as
we all know recently, there have been
people that have done that, and it's
just kind of confusing. But for whatever
that's worth, I just thought I would I
would throw it out there. So, what I'm
going to do today is this is basically a
mystery. I talked about epigenetics last
time and that's basically when things
happen to the genes or to the process of
going from genes to proteins and
building our bodies and then we have
this problem and we're trying to solve
it and can we use diet or not and that's
a big thing that we do. We're trying to
make sure we all get all the nutrients
we need so that we can do the functions
that our body's able to do. We have to
try to be able to do that. So, here's
what happened. Basically, my husband and
I
had a business where we trained and
showed horses when I was young. And we
would go to these horse shows. And this
was in the in the 1980s from 1980
through 1983.
We did the Minnesota Quarter Horse
Association circuit. So, we went to all
the quarter horse shows. And quarter
horses are a specific breed, usually
known for being muscly muscly horses,
but there's an association for that. So,
we went to about 40 shows a year
doing that, the breed, you know, those
breed shows in the state of Minnesota
where we where we lived. And we actually
won in in 1980 the High Point all-around
horse in that association. And then each
of those four years, we won the High
Point performance horse, high point per
performance geling and things like that.
So that's what we're basically famous
for for doing that. But while we were at
those shows, we did the speed events,
the barrel racing, pole bending, and so
basically speed. But each day they would
have the whole show, and they start out
the shows with halter, which is where
you're just looking at the animal.
You're looking at their musling. You're
looking at how they're built. So that's
more like a a you know what are the
jeans or what does the horse look like
and while we were going to those shows
some of the horses started and it was it
was mainly the ones doing the halter
classes.
They would they would have this weird
shaking that they call faciciculations
and they would have called the vets out
and they would be you know trying to
deal with this and this went on for
years probably 10 or more years and some
of them would even be found dead in
their stalls in the morning it was
really a bad thing.
So at the time that I was doing my PhD
research at Texas A&M, which was later,
it was 1990. I was down there from 90
through95,
there was a big breakthrough that they
found the genetic cause of that
disorder. So we knew what it was, what
caused it, and I decided to to do my
project on it. There's a magazine called
Aquis and the horse people know what
that is, but I was actually a charter
subscriber. It it's a magazine that
would come every month and they would
talk about what's going on with the
medical stuff with horses. That's it was
basically anatomy physiology, all the
stuff going on, not a riding what's
going on with riding, but what's going
on with the physiology of horses. And
there was an issue of that that said
unmasking the fatal flaw. And it was
about the genetic discovery of HYPP,
what it is. And it happened to be at a
time, like I said, where I was
interested in it. But the other thing
was at Texas A&M, as part of the horses
that they keep, they they breed and
train and show horses and sell them.
They have to have them for the students
to use. And they happen to have one
group of horses that went back to the
Stallion Impressive. I'll show you in a
minute. But but this this problem
happened to be in descendants of that
horse. So at the college I was at
University Texas A&M, there were
actually horses that had that disorder.
Some that did and some that didn't. But
the interesting thing there is none of
us knew that they were even having
symptoms of it because if you're fed a
certain way, they don't have symptoms
which we're we're coming to. So, you
know, it becomes kind of a fascinating
thing. But in order to sell, I believe
it was the 2-year-olds or something from
that one year there were they started
having rules once they figured out what
it was. And if you're going to send a
horse to sale, you have to test it and
make sure that it doesn't have it or if
it does. So, those horses were all put
up for sale. And they were all tested.
And they were shocked at Texas&M to find
out that roughly half of those horses
had it, which is statistically what you
would get, about half. And so I'm going,
"Wow, perfect." And I planned and put
this whole project together. So I'm
going to I'm going to go ahead and start
out and do some definitions. But key
things that we're doing as we're trying
to solve this mystery, again, we found
out the genetics.
So we're going to look at the gene, the
genetics. We're going to look at the
physiology. It has to do with muscle
cell membranes, thus the muscle, you
know, the faciciculations and things. It
also has to do with the heart, the
functioning of the heart, and it's the
electrical conduction system. So we're
going to look at some of those EEGs and
those kinds of things. We're going to
look at both human and horse versions,
and then we're going to go through how
the project was designed, what the
results were, and how the basic mystery
was solved, and how we can now feed
them. So, again, this is a this is a
mystery, but it covers all kinds of of
disciplines and all kinds of things that
I think are interesting. Um, and so
that's that's the payoff here is that
it's the process. We're going to go
through the process. All right. So here
we go.
Okay. So again it's called hyperc calmic
periodic paralysis. And we'll define it.
First thing it's always nice to define
things.
Okay. So hyper is from the Greek meaning
hoop. Hooper meaning above or excessive
too much. Calemic is the Latin. Calium
is potassium in Latin. Periodic means
repeated cycles. You know, sometimes it
it's happening, sometimes it's not going
in cycles. And paralysis, inability to
move. Okay? So, that's why it was named.
They used the symptoms and that's how it
was named. But it's got a bunch of other
names, too. Remember, everything gets
named more than once. So, we'll see
those in a second here. So,
just to introduce it, we know that it's
co-ominantly inherited. What that means
is that
a horse can have symptoms when they have
only one. We're looking at the whole
thing where you get one gene from the
mother, one from the father, and if they
they only have one, they'll have a
certain set of problems, but if they
have both, they have even more. So, it's
it's not just um if if it's a recessive
type thing instead, then the the ones
that have one copy don't have any
symptoms. You don't even know they're
sick, but they carry it. Okay? So,
that's not what this is. this is
dominant. So, we knew that we know it
affects muscle function. They pretty
quickly figured out that all the horses
that had this were a descendant. Now,
they could be a son or daughter. They
could be a grandson or granddaughter.
They could be a grandson or
granddaughter. They could go, you know,
generation after generation, they could
have this.
So, but they did trace them all back.
Okay? And then the thing is there was a
large variation in symptoms. They had
several years of these horses at Texas
A&M and never realized or knew the vets
there. I had two veterinarians on my
committee to do this this project and
you know they're like no we've never
seen it. Of course we didn't know what
they didn't know what it was but they
never saw what other people were talking
about.
Okay. And then there they did f have
that genetic test. So what we found of
course is that you have to manage them
since they might be a little bit sick or
not sick at all or a lot sick. We had to
figure out how to manage it and that's
where the that's where the diet starts
to come in. Okay, this is what the horse
looked like. This is um from Equis
magazine.
Um and this is what you'd call a you
know a beautifully shaped muscular
quarter horse. Okay. Now the thing about
this is people when people see a horse
like that they breed for his qualities.
So he was a very popular sire and that's
why if this horse had been a badl
looking horse out in somebody's pasture
he probably would have been galded and
no one have ever heard of this disease.
But because he was so nicel lookinging
he was a top sire and had a lot of
offspring. And there's a key thing about
that that we're going to talk about a
minute, too.
Okay. So, when you're doing research
like this, you do a literature review.
So, I went through and I looked at I had
to learn about potassium metabolism. I
had to learn about that genetic mutation
and other things about genetics. I had
to learn the mechanism of action. How
does it work? What are the symptoms that
that people see and the diagnosis? And
then what do the veterinarians do to
treat something like this?
So, here we go. Potassium metabolism.
Now, I'm going to show you a diagram in
a couple minutes. I'm going to go
through this, but then I'm going to show
you a diagram. And that's sort of
confusing, but it's better than all
these words. But, um, so what happens
with potassium? Okay, we have
if we if we look at the internal makeup
of the muscle, you have cells. Each
individual cell has a lot of potassium
in the cell and then in the blood we
have a lot of sodium.
And so for muscle cell membranes to what
they call fire, for a muscle to work, to
move,
you have shifts between
the the potassium that's in the cell and
the sodium that's outside the cell. And
they actually you have pores and and
ways that they that they can
interchange. And when that happens the
muscle can move. Okay. So that's
required.
So what happens is potassium itself is
the principal intracellular cation. So
so it's inside the cell. Cation means
it's a positive charge. Okay. Um so it's
missing an electron. So it maintains the
cell volume and allows for that
electrical activity. Now this whole
thing is regulated by hormones. Those
are chemical messengers that go from one
part of the body to another, mainly in
the kidneys, the adrenal glands, which
are above the kidneys, the thyroid
gland, and the pancreas. You're probably
familiar with all of those. Most
potassium is absorbed from the small
intestine, but a small amount from the
large. I actually did a separate study
on top of this with ponies that had been
there from another study. And so they
had a canula that goes in between the
small and large intestine. And we could
take out some of the digesta
before it went all the way through and
then at the end. And we and we were able
to figure out that most of it does get
absorbed in the small intestine, but
some of it in the large. That was a
whole separate thing that I did. Okay.
So mostly it's going to get absorbed and
the potassium that they eat is going to
get absorbed and be in the blood. So
once it's in the blood, the main way to
excrete it is the kidneys. That's how we
get rid of our, you know, the liquid
things. But there's some will come out,
the feces, sweat, and dermis, which is
skin. It'll be in the skin cells, and
all those cells have a lot of potassium.
So when you shed skin, you know, that's
going to that's going to go too. Here's
a key thing right here. Horses require
3% to 8% of their dry matter intake. And
that's just a way that we measure. A
horse gets about 20 to 30 lbs. An 1100lb
horse gets about 20 to 30 lb of dry
matter as feed and hay or
they're going to eat pasture which is
70% water and then you know you just
calculate it by the percentage of water
in the diet. But look at this. Common
feeds
supply.3
to 6%.
Okay, this is what they need. And here
almost 10 times as much. So literally
almost all horses are getting too much
potassium every day all the time and
they have to get rid of it. Okay, normal
horses. But they can get rid of it. They
don't have a problem. But these horses
do. They have this big problem trying to
get rid of it.
Okay. And here's the part about humans.
Now, this is when I did the research.
Um, I was doing this in about
93. I had I finished my actual master's
work in 93 and started working on this.
And so, I did the literature review at
that time and I found seven or 18
misssense mutations. It's in the same
channel. I'm going to show you this. I
don't know why my pointer isn't showing
up here, but I'm going to show you a
picture of this. So, again, I I'll go
through it and then I'll show you a
picture. There is this skeletal muscle
sodium channel. So, the purpose of it is
to open up and let the sodium go through
it. That's what that CN4A does. That's
its job.
And in humans, there is one called the
same thing, hypercalemic periodic
paralysis. It's also called adanmia,
episodica, hereditaria.
It's called gamorps disease, hypocalemic
periodic paralysis. And those are people
where they at the time it happens they
don't have enough potassium in their
blood. Then there's paramiotonia
congenita
and um PMC of von yulenberg and myotonia
congenita. These are all things that I
found in the literature that can happen
to people. This will make more sense as
I show you the the graph, the chart.
Okay, let's also go through this one
before I get to the the other diagram.
Okay, they had two people
with h HPP,
what they were calling it in in uh the
human literature there. And then they
had I believe it was nine normal
subjects. So what they did is several
times repeatedly
they gave these these people this is you
can see here um this is their potassium
content here in the in the venus blood
in the veins. And then
this is 8 in the morning. This is a meal
12 noon a meal 8 uh 6 pm I believe a
meal. and then um 12 midnight, 6:00
a.m.,
12 noon, and 6:00 p.m. Okay, so they got
meals at these times. Okay, you can see
the normal people at a somewhere around
and then they're
you can see that it stayed in a pretty
much the same range around almost four.
And the normal range people say is 3.5
to 4.5 is supposed to be the normal
range of potassium. It's kind of a
useless concept, but that's what they
basically said it was. But you can see
that these people that had this
mutation, now my pointer is working. You
can see how
at the meal it would go up and it went
up to five. This one went up to five and
a quarter or something like that. So you
can see that after each meal. So in
other words, the meal was the source of
the extra potassium
and and it would go up like that. Okay.
So this is people that was humans.
Okay.
So now how do these two compare the
horses and the people? Okay. The human
hyp is similar to one human mutation. So
it's basically the same mutation. The
other ones are close but not in the same
place on the sodium channel. Again, I'll
show you that in a minute. So, Ecoin HPP
is also called HPPP
hyper PPP PIPP for potassium induced
periodic paralysis because again people
in one place call it one thing, they
call it something else somewhere else.
But the one um so we know that there is
this one mutation and we don't know what
else you know they may have something
else also happening but we're if they do
we're not aware of it and at the time I
was doing this
there were an estimated 4% of all
register quarter horses but again these
were in the bloodlines of the horses
that did halter were muscular not the
ones that raced or did western pleasure
or you know jumping or any of these
other things. Okay.
So, we know it's a genetic mutation and
we know it's autotoal. Autotoomal. What
that means is that it's not on the X and
Y chromosomes that determine sex gender.
Okay? It's on the body cells in the
muscles muscle cells. So, in other
words, it shouldn't matter. It shouldn't
be more common in male or female. And we
find out that that it's not. So, here's
what happens in the DNA. Okay, you're
supposed to have a guanine in this one
in this location. That's a specific
way that it can be configured. And
instead of it, you have cytosine. It's a
different one, which leads to a
different amino acid. You have leucine
instead of phenol alanine. Phenol
alanine. And leucine and phenol alanine.
Leucine has has less
um atoms on it. It's smaller. It's
physically smaller, but the place where
it connects is the same. The shape is
the same, but then this one's smaller,
which allows the leaking of the of the
sodium. And this just tells you where it
is. The X6 region of domain 4 of the
alpha subunit of the voltage dependent
sodium channel protein of muscle cell
membranes. That's where it is and
results in leaking of sodium through the
pore. Okay. Now, here's we're going to
start seeing the pictures.
All right.
So, this is what would be what is a
membrane.
Okay. Along the membrane,
here's the outside of the cell like the
blood. Here's the inside of the cell.
Down here at the bottom is the inside of
the cell. And you can see there are four
units, four subunits. They're going to
form a circle and and become a pore. If
you look right here, this is the exact
location where you have that lucine
instead of phenol alanine and you have
that defective pore right here. These
other things that were found in people
here, there's one over here on the other
side of the number six. If you can't, my
pointer is not working on the very right
side. And then here you can see some of
these other locations for paramatonia
congenita. You see it right here. Um
it's on the right side of the of the
three the number green one. the green
one, the third one. And then over here
you have you have HPP3ine
um replaces methionine. So this just
shows you how little mistakes can happen
in different places all on that same
pore. And here's what it looks like when
you put it into the membrane. So it
folds. This is the stretched out version
that we just looked at. And then it
folds into this place. And this is the
pore in the middle. And this is what it
looks like floating in the cell
membrane.
So that's what we're looking at inside
the muscle cell. Okay. Kind of cool,
especially if you like to do if you like
to um color things, if you like to make
drawings and color them. Okay, I'm just
going to quickly do this because it's
not terribly relevant, but they looked
in order to find out how many of these
horses there were. They took samples
from 1992 to 96. They all traced to
impressive. And they found
63% were normal, 36% were
hetererozygous. In other words, they had
one defective and one normal gene. And
then only 1% were homozygous.
So they were they were doubles. Okay.
And then they also looked at stored
samples
and they found 4% and 0% and 96%. So
earlier on not as many but then we're
getting more and more and more of these
horses with the problem.
So here comes the mechanism of action
which is is also fun but you know um so
that extra there is extra potassium in
the diet or from any reason but it's
usually diet. There are other ways you
can get it too but whenever the
potassium goes up in the blood doesn't
matter why potassium goes up in the
blood pressure. So you have two positive
ions and you're supposed to have sodium
in the blood. You have too much
potassium and the sodium starts leaking
through the muscle cell and it's you
know people have gotten this wrong a lot
trying to talk about it. It's not a
potassium channel. It's too much
potassium but it's a sodium only
channel. Okay? So it leaks through that
through that. Then the muscles deolarize
and fire again because that's what
they're supposed to do. So they'll start
shaking. you'll see the symptoms.
Then the potassium is going to leave the
cell on once the potassium comes in.
Then the body, it flips, deolarizes, and
it's and all of a sudden you're trying
to get the potassium back in the cell
and the sodium back out of the cell.
You'll see a picture in a minute. And so
then the increased extracellular
potassium and then the potassium is
excreted by the kidneys
and then you have re-uptake again. And
so you're it's trying to it's trying to
fix itself by putting these ions back
where they belong.
Hopefully the picture is easier to
understand. All right. This is the
wonderful
creation of this.
If the pointer isn't working u Oh, it is
good. Okay. So we have dietary potassium
coming in. We have increased potassium.
Uh that also increases insulin and it
changes you know some other things here.
But this pore doesn't work correctly. So
with all this extra potassium, we have
the sodium leaking in. Okay? When sodium
leaks in, the muscle fires, it starts
shaking and then you have sodium going
out
because there's too much because we got
to get the potassium back in. And here's
the main way it comes back in. You have
this ATPAS. It uses energy and it kicks
out sodium and brings potassium back in.
And in the working muscle,
it actually helps
to fix this if the horse is walking or
some, you know, sometimes they can even
trot, but you got to be careful. Okay.
So, anyway, the basic thing is happening
here that it's fixing it. It's all
trying to fix it. Up here, we're just
showing that we're going to the adrenal
gland. We're increasing the hormone
eldoststerone
which is causing more excretion of
potassium through the kidneys and we're
resolving this whole thing and getting
it back so that it can fire again. Like
if the horse was going to be running we
would have to keep fixing it and for you
know the it's a good thing that when a
horse is moving this tends to fix
itself.
Okay. But if it can't fix itself fast
enough, they can fall down and they can
be dangerous. All right, so we're in the
weeds here. Okay,
again, clinical symptoms, wide range.
There are diseases like this is
breakdown of muscle, rabdo, myolyis,
collic, seizures, respiratory
conditions, a choke. These were the
things that were already happening that
vets knew about, but they had never
heard of this. So they misdiagnosed it.
You have um faciciculations. you have
muscle stiffness. They will look weak.
They will yawn. Now, these horses did
not feel bad. They did not They were not
panicking or, you know, feeling bad.
They were just, you know, doing their
thing. There's a third eyelid, a
membrane that can cross their eye.
That's a kind of a dead giveaway for
that. I'll show you the dog sitting in a
second. It means they're, you know,
they're down,
can't get up normally, and then of
course they can find them in their stall
or they have to be euthanized, which is
sad. There's what the dog sitting looks
like. They're treating them. So they can
they can sit up, but they can't stand.
Okay.
Now, the other thing which is totally
different than the muscles is the heart.
And again, I like I said, it's the
electrical conduction system of the
heart that causes your Well, I'll show
you what it looks like. Okay, here's an
ECG electroc cardiogram.
And let's see, these are the horses. So,
at potassium of 4.3,
this is your normal, you know what it
looks like, an electroc cardiogram, your
heart. It's it's the beating of your
heart. When potassium goes up to 5.3,
it's stretching out. You can see that up
to eight. Look at how stretched out it
is.
And this is where it'll just stop
beating. If it stretches out too much,
it will literally just stop beating. And
here they gave the horse calcium.
Um, we did calcium gluconate.
Both glucose and calcium help put it
back together, get the potassium back in
the cells. So, they're just showing what
could happen. And here's basically what
it looks like in the horses or heart
failure. I mean, this could actually be
either one. So, here's your normal, you
know, heartbeat, heartbeat, heartbeat,
heartbeat. So, at five to 6.5 is
starting to stretch out. At 6.5 is more
stretch out. And eight, it's not a
normal heartbeat. Heart rhythm stops.
Horse dies or person.
Okay.
So, two things are happening. So, how
did they diagnose it?
Uh, they started with hair. They start I
think they started with blood, but then
they're able to do it. You have to pull
the hair out by the roots and send it in
and they're able to fix it. And they had
some other ways to figure it out here
before
they they had the DNA test. they used um
muscle electro um myograms, cardiograms,
or they fed them potassium and watched
to see what happened. And obviously if
that horse has it, that could be
dangerous. Now, here's here's the key
takeaway right here. This is huge.
They they said if a horse had high
potassium, then it had hpp.
that horses actually start having
symptoms in my research at about 3.79,
which is right in the middle of normal
potassium. So, if you're trying to
diagnose with high potassium, you're
going to miss virtually every one of
these horses. I'll show you how in a
minute. How are we doing for time? Okay,
so we know that we have to do dietary
management. That's something that I
ended up proving. But before that, you
don't want them in a stall. You want
them to move around. They were actually
feeding a diuretic which causes them to
urinate more called acettoolamide.
And that was they would put them on
these horse these horses on them all the
time. And it did work. It helped if
they're having an episode calcium
carbonate. Now again, these things work
for people too. There's similar problems
in a very few people.
Okay. So before you do research, you
don't know the history, you have
symptoms in progress and you don't know
anything else about that horse.
So you can use that to develop a
research hypothesis. And when you do the
research, you know the history and you
use it to design the research. You
monitor before, during, and after the
symptoms. You control other variables
and that's big. You can't you can't do a
nutrition study if you don't control the
exercise.
Okay. Um right.
All right. So the objectives
document and quantify HYPP episodes
in the positive and negative horses. I
used varying concentrations of potassium
three different concentrations and we
couldn't exercise them. We no first
exercise. They lived in in groups of two
>> recording stopped.
>> Okay, I don't know what to do about
that. I guess you guys have to start the
recording.
>> Recording in progress.
>> Okay, so again, we're going to quantify
the episodes.
We're going to feed three concentrations
of potassium
and then we're going we're going to
that was my separate research uh
quantify differences in potassium
absorption and excretion. So a bunch of
things we were doing.
So the diets we had to use 65%
concentrate or a pellet and then only
35% hay. Normally a horse would be fed
about 90% hay and 10% concentrate. But
we in order to get the potassium in we
had to use a potassium source.
So what we did is we fed them two meals
a day very you know timed exactly and we
fed them at 12-hour interval intervals
exactly 12 hours apart. We formulated
using the NRC minimum for maintenance.
We made sure we met all their nutrient
needs.
So we had three concentrations. We had
diet A with no added potassium and it
had 1.1% potassium. The idea was for it
to be 1 2 and three. And then when we
actually analyzed it at the end it was
1.1 1.9 and 2.9 is what they ended up to
be. And these are colorcoded.
So we used 12 mature quarter horse
broodmares descendants of impressive DNA
tested to be HN or normal. We randomly
assigned two of each into three groups
and of course we did all their routine
health maintenance. So this was the
Latin square.
So on the first group got diet C and
then diet B and then diet A. In the
first group, period one, group one got
diet C, group two got diet A, and group
three got diet B. And again, the one
point one, two, I put two and three, but
it's, you know,
so for each part of the Latin square, we
spent seven days getting them used to
the diet.
Then we we drew their blood for
potassium concentration. And this whole
time we were observing them. We had
notebooks. We had people watching. We I
had students watching the horses and
making notes of if they were having any
faciciculations or any issues with their
muscles. And then we drew the blood
again at day 21.
Okay. So day eight and day 21 we drew
blood and we compared the blood from the
beginning to the end.
This again was a different project that
I used the ponies for and we found that
98% of the potassium was absorbed before
the hind gut. So in the stomach and
small intestine very absorbable.
This is different than it would be in
nature because we added a we added
potassium citrate which is you know it's
a it's easy to absorb. So if the
potassium was in the hay it would be
harder to absorb. So obviously this is a
research thing that we found out but
99.9% of the potassium in the diet was
absor was absorbed.
Most of it almost all of it was excreted
in the urine with a minor amount going
out in the feces. In other words, that
didn't get absorbed.
But here's when it starts to get
interesting. More was retained from diet
B than diet A or C. And there was no
difference by HP status.
So as we fed these diets, the way they
they were able to absorb, digest,
utilize, and get rid of the potassium
was the same with the HYPP and the
normal horses. So this is kind of
fascinating.
Okay, this will this will be easier when
I show you the diagrams.
Okay, we saw a pattern after meal postr
postprandial in plasma potassium from
diets B and C
between meal the first meal and meal 27
they got better they adjusted to the
extra potassium and and got better at
getting rid of it. Another fascinating
thing we had increased average potassium
after diet B and again no difference by
HYPP status. So, we were learning how
horses metabolize potassium. And this is
what it looked like. The horses, the
positive horses up here, the negative
here.
And you can see they started out. Now,
this is this is 3.5 and 3.7. So, they
were slightly different,
but when they were fed, bingo, it goes
up here. it kind of, you know, and this
is the difference between the potassium
that's getting absorbed through the
front of the horse. Remember
the citrate, the potassium citrate, the
it's like if you ate salt versus if you
got salt out of the food you're eating.
Okay, so that's why I think we got this
little dip here. Okay,
now here's the fun part by diet.
So all the horses were put back
together, the hppp positive and negative
all put back together. So on diet A
pretty much I mean I mean this is 3.25
doesn't basically change, okay? Because
they were just getting a normal diet,
1.1% potassium.
Diet two, again, there was a little bit
of a difference in those horses to start
with and stayed a lot higher. And diet
C, which was the most, is weird. It went
up and it came down quicker. And the
only thing I can think of for this is
that it was such a shock that they just
worked really hard and got rid of it
sooner. But that's not the key thing.
When we do the symptoms, that'll make
more sense. Okay. So, HYP symptoms if
okay if there are no symptoms it's a
symptom sympto symptom index and this is
something I had to create because we had
to have a way to explain the
relationship between the blood potassium
and the symptoms. So zero they didn't
have any one point we divided the body
into five sections the head and neck the
front quarters the body and the hind
quarters
and into five sections so that we could
say you know at this time
were their faciciculations on one
through five one you know of those
different five areas then if they had a
problem moving like it looked like they
couldn't move their front or highindord
ers, that was another one point for one
or both of them. If the third eyelid
prolapsed, that was another point. And
if they actually went down, if they
actually could not stay up, that was
two. So it could be 10. So you could
have a horse with zero symptoms at time
6:00 a.m. and then they could go all the
way to 10 at time 10:00 a.m. for one
individual horse.
Okay. So, the results of the symptom
index, diet A, they didn't have any
symptoms. They were not um it didn't
matter if they were positive or negative
HP, they didn't have any symptoms. Okay?
Normal diet, 1.1% potassium. Diet B, and
this is is the percentage of of
potassium. No, wait a minute.
No, this is symptoms. Okay. So,
at the first meal, they had symptoms
one and a half% of the time. And here
they had two four. Okay. This is I'm I'm
looking at the wrong slide. Hang on a
second. Sorry.
Symptoms. Okay. Right. The symptom index
is one part of the body. It goes from 1
to 10. So, we had a 1.59
here and then we had a one over here,
right? So zero. These would be zeros. I
was thinking blood here. Okay. So, so
not very many symptoms. I mean, that's
good. But then on diet C, they had a
2.42
after
the first time. And then the symptoms
went down and they were the same from
diet C after 27 meals and down here. So
again, this is this is physiology
of how
the the HYPP symptoms happened relative
to the diet. Uh okay.
Okay.
Here's the one.
If they didn't have HP, they didn't have
any symptoms at all. Okay.
if they were fed diet A and they had the
the disease, the disorder, again, no
symptoms because they didn't get enough
potassium to trigger that defective
sodium channel. But here's the weird
part.
After 52% of the meals, so half the time
when they got a meal, they had some
symptoms.
Okay? They had at least one symptom half
the time. And when they were fed diet C,
they had at least one symptom. Twothirds
of the time after every meal,
twothirds of the time they would have
symptoms. This is huge. That's a lot of
of a problem.
Okay. So, I covered that, covered that,
covered that. Now, the other interesting
thing, they were twice as common in the
daytime, the symptoms, as they were at
night. And I explain that later on, but
there's kind of a post-prandial thing
where when you're, you know, you're
quiet at night, it alters your um
eldoststerone, your your hormones and
things like that. That kind of explains
that they're quieter at night than they
are during the day. Again, this probably
is the biggest takeaway for
anybody with horses, anybody with people
looking at diet, potassium, and
physiology
because it was the amount of potassium
in the blood
that mattered. And it didn't matter if
they got it from diet A, diet B, or diet
C. when the potassium went up and and
this it was for diet but for any reason
that the potassium went up. Look at how
narrow this range is. 3.74 3.81 3.78 and
3.84
how how narrow this range is. That's
when the the symptoms were triggered.
Okay. So that's like the magic line and
that's why we have to recommend the low
potassium diets. So it's when the blood
gets to a certain point that that cell
those muscle cells defective cells don't
work correctly. So at average of 3.79
mill moles per liter you can start
having symptoms. All right.
And it got better from meal one to meal
27 which means they adapted. This is
something that they that could have
killed them and they actually adapted to
it.
And so therefore, you know, the the
plasma potassium got lower and so did
the symptoms because because they're
related. Now, here's where hopefully
it'll make a little more sense. So, you
have diet and symptoms. All right.
The diet A, no extra potassium, 1%. The
blue one is diet B and the red one is
diet C. Okay. So, and here's their
plasma potassium. So, this is blood and
then this is symptoms down here. blood
right here. Again, you can see that line
right here at that 3.71 or 3.84 or
whatever it is. When the blood got to
one of these levels, that's when the
symptoms started. It's it's very direct.
See right here is where that arrow is
and that's where the symptoms started.
And this is what they did with symptoms.
And then this is what they did with diet
C, the most potassium. And see how the
symptoms are. I mean, the blood is
higher. It literally it literally
follows the symptoms. They correlate
with each other.
Okay. In this particular one, this is
blood and symptoms. But before we
started this, I mean the the results
that I've just given you were the actual
trial. But before we did that, we tried
it
one time
and we had we were giving too much
potassium.
So, one horse when we were first trying
this out, this is what happened with
her. She actually went all the way to
sternal recumbancy and her blood
potassium went up to 7.5. Okay, this is
one horse, one trial
and this is what happened on the first
day all the way up. high symptoms, high
blood potassium. And again,
by day 27, she barely went up above that
line and had a had symptoms for a short
time.
Okay, so it's really showing the
physiology.
Okay,
we are all right. 51. All right. So, so
the main thing I want to do here now is
how do we take this research and how do
we use it? What is it telling us because
all of this is is um I do this is where
I do the conclusions of my particular
research. But then what I what I went on
and did all of these things had been
questioned. And so this is after some of
this is several years, 10, 15, maybe
even years after my research where other
research came in and I talked about it
and just, you know, explained that these
other factors are not as important as
diet. And so let me let me just run
through and see if any of these I need
to do that are going to help.
Okay, this is a big one. The reason that
people were breeding to this horse
because they like the muscle in the
horse was that they thought that the
horses that were HYPP positive had
heavier musling and therefore would win
more halter classes and that's why
people wanted those horses. Even though
they were sick, they wanted them. This
research proved that that's not true.
And I could have told you that because
the horses that I was around, some of
them you'd look at them and they were
heavily muscled, but they didn't have
it. And some of them were not heavily
muscled, but they did. And this was a
big deal because people with those
horses, they were valuable and they were
worried, you know, they didn't want to
give them up and all this was going on.
But this, it was proven that the musling
and the HYPP disorder were not the same
cause. They were two different causes.
So this is like when you're looking at a
cause of something, we use AAM's eraser,
which says the simplest explanation is
usually correct. In this case, it was a
zebra
because you had two causes,
two completely separate causes, and you
had to find that out. That was a key
thing you had to find out. So, thank you
for the zebra, Albert. Um, okay. We also
found out they used to think that it was
age related, but if you look at the milk
of a mare feeding her baby, it's got
more potassium, right? When the baby's
small, and as it gets older, there's
less potassium in the milk. And all the
babies that had both, they were they had
both defective genes were very sick as
fos. So all of these had moms that also
had it where most of the ones that had
one gene that was defective and one
wasn't. Most of them got the defective
gene from the stallion. So the mayor's
milk was not affecting them the same
way. Okay? They had one good gene, one
not, but they didn't the mare the mar's
milk her physiology wasn't affecting it.
I was just a baby. All right. again not
dependent. They all they thought at the
beginning that it was the males would
get it but no it's autotoal doesn't
affect that isn't affected.
Um
you know again some of these things day
versus night a circadian pattern of
potassium excretion has been reported in
humans. So there will be differences.
Like I said I did talk about that
these the animals that had both of these
were very sick. I didn't have any of
these. But again, if they were really
sick as a foe, they may not have made
it.
So, the fact that it was the blood
itself, the amount of potassium in the
blood for these horses that that had the
mutation is important. The fact that
they were able to adjust,
okay, those were important things about
it. and exercise.
Only a nonex exercising muscle can have
HYPP symptoms because every time the
muscle fires to work, it starts the
whole thing over. So only if it is
sitting there
and that's why you have to control the
exercise,
right?
And again, that's my theory.
I'm just going to I think I'm just going
to There were other things at the
beginning. Um
they thought that the stress of weaning,
transport, surgery, anesthesia, all
these things. And by the way, those
horses do do have a very bad reaction to
anesthesia
because again it it change it changes
the the physiology. So, we keep the diet
up below 1.1% potassium or we let them
graze because all the potassium that
they eat in the grass, the grass is 70
80% water and it spreads the potassium
out. Okay. All right. I don't think
there's anything else on here that's
going to be super relevant now.
Oh, what happened with the breed
associations? Okay, all breed
associations for cats, dogs, horses,
everything, they have certain rules. If
they classify something as a genetic
defect, they want to breed it out of the
population. For instance, with horses,
there's always been um you cannot
register horses that have what's called
a parrot mouth. Parrot mouth means if
your I don't know if I can do it with my
hand here in front of me, but it means
that if the upper teeth are way sticking
out in front, like if your upper jaw is
sticking out and your and your lower jaw
is low, those horses have that defect
and they can't eat normally. They're not
they're not going to survive. So that
you cannot register your horse if it has
that. And there are a whole bunch of
other ones. If they only have one
testicle descended, that's a trait they
don't want. So there were always these
traits. So in 1992 they started noting
it. You had to get your horse tested for
registration
and then they you know they started this
mandatory testing but you had to have it
on the registration certificate. So if a
person bought this horse they would not
be you know unaware of a genetic defect
that that horse had. As of 2007 they
would not register the HH horses. But
then people again they like the muscle
so they were still breeding the other
ones and they stopped registering all of
these horses the NH horses probably 10
12 years ago I don't remember exactly
when but the different breed
associations did different things. So
again, a an association,
a breeder of of, you know, horses, dogs,
cats, cows, anything.
It's the ethics within that organization
that's going to decide whether they're
allowing things like this to keep going
on. I mean, we have the animals. We take
care of the ones we have. We do the best
we can, but we don't perpetuate a
problem that they can't live normally is
is basically what this is about. Oh, I
do want to say this just real quickly.
These are different different genetic
mutations in horses that horse people
have to deal with. HP is in the sodium
channel. Glycogen storage,
polysaccharide storage, or myopathy.
They have to have a low starch ration.
Um, reer recurrent exertional
rabdtomyolysis. Another one muscle uh
muscles get broken down. They have to
have a low starch diet. bone formation,
developmental orthopedic disease, they
have to have low low starch or low um
glycemic index rations. There is a low
amace. They don't have the en enzyme to
break down amalayise which can result in
founder. You can give them enzymes or a
low starch ration. Um horses with a lot
of weight markings, they can have
photosensitive
problems and you don't feed them all
sight clover. So again, there are a lot
of things out there. I just got to show
you my those are my
and they're not HP. I never had I never
owned HP horses cuz I knew what the
problem was.
Okay,
questions.
>> Anyone have any questions? That was
a lot to cover, Dr. J.
>> And that's that's the problem with it.
But there was no place to stop in the
middle. So,
>> no, no, I'm not complaining.
>> Not complaining at all. And it's very
interesting how what you saw proved that
even with a a mutated gene,
diet made a difference. Mhm.
>> And then it was also very interesting
and that's probably why the
in the name it says periodic is the time
of day made a difference.
>> So so very interesting. So now the
question is and Kathy has put this
question up and this is a question that
I was going to ask as well is how does
this translate to human needs for
potassium?
Okay,
first of all, I was comparing normal
horses
with it. Normal as far as that sodium
channel is concerned with horses with
this disorder.
So, I have never met anyone with this
any human being with this problem. I've
researched it, but I've never met a
human with it. And we're unlikely to
meet humans that have this. So, we're
going to throw away
a I mean, if there is a human that
actually has this, then they have to
very carefully control what they eat and
not get too much potassium, just like a
horse would. But here's the difference
between horses and people. The main diet
of a horse is hay, forage, pasture, and
they all have
somewhere around 1% to two and even up
to 3% potassium in their normal food.
The diets that people eat,
we tend to to eat too much salt if we
heavily salted snacks and all those
kinds of things.
But we've been told to keep cutting back
on our salt, cut back on our salt, cut
back on our salt, which is incorrect
because we need sodium chloride
in order to for our to form the stomach
acid, the hydrochloric acid that helps
us break down the minerals and the
proteins and stuff in our stomach. So,
your average person doesn't get enough
potassium if they don't eat a lot of
vegetables.
And how many people do you know that eat
a lot of vegetables?
And you will find with people, almost
all older people
get put on added potassium to make sure
they have enough because they can draw
your blood and preferably it's fasting.
This is why when when people say you get
your blood drawn, fasting means you
didn't eat in the last 12 hours. You saw
how that potassium went up and down
after each meal in those hor in those
people,
right?
>> So, you're draw your blood can be drawn
if you're an elderly person. You're not
eating very much. You might not have
someone to cook for you. You might not
get vegetables very often. If your
potassium is low, you're not you're
going to feel terrible and it's an
essential nutrient. And so
we need to make sure as people that
we're getting enough sodium or I'm sorry
potassium. And we have a good mechanism
as long as our kidneys work well. And
you can see from my diagram, you're
trying to get rid of that extra
potassium. Whatever you eat, horses are
always eating too much potassium.
They're getting rid of it through the
kidneys. So if you have kidney problems
then you are going to have potassium
problems
right? So for people we have to eat more
sodium than they tell us. We have to eat
probably double and I did talk about
that in that salt lecture. People can
you can go out and look at one of the
ones I did before called salt of the
earth. And we went through you know a
lot of that information and Dr. Wallock
talks about that a lot. That's one of
the things he talks about. But as far as
potassium is concerned, you do have to
get enough
and there's a there's always a caution
with potassium. And that's why
a doctor can only or a pharmacist or
whoever formulates can only do a small
amount of potassium in each tablet
because you saw how the high potassium
actually stopped the electrical
conduction system of the heart.
It's actually used as a euthanasia
um
shot, whatever they do for an animal
that's that has to be euthanized. They
use high potassium.
So, you have to be very careful with it.
It's not something you just go around
and add too much or, you know, or mess
around with it. Okay? So, hopefully
that's not confusing. You you can check
your potassium level if you don't think
you eat enough vegetables.
because that's where most of the
potassium is is in the vegetables,
right? That's also in meat too.
So every every cell it's in the cells
and the sodium is in the tissues
like blood, that type of thing. Did that
answer the question? I hope. I don't
know.
>> Um I think so. I think so. But from what
all this stuff I said about potassium
and horses, it's not the same as us
because we don't eat hay and forage as a
normal diet. We eat other things. People
eat other things and those things don't
have as much potassium usually as the
things horses eat. Okay.
>> Well, and even the things that in nature
would have potassium,
we eat it in a processed form.
Yeah, that's
>> that reduces all the nutritional value.
>> Right. Right.
>> Yeah. And then we have Harry um the
healer out on Rumble. U I can read part
of this Harry, but he does say how um he
it is interesting information that the
horse was our gift from the creator. And
he
>> he says, "Thank you."
>> And let's go over to
Huh?
>> I just said thank you, Harry.
>> Oh, gotcha.
>> Key, go ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Hi, Dr. Judy. How are you today?
>> Hi, Kaylee. I'm great. How are you?
>> Oh, fantastic. Um, so really what you're
telling us is that potassium is sort of
like the metabolic barometer for us,
whether we're animal and or human being.
Well, potassium
varies. Okay, here here
you opened a door. Okay,
plants are based on potassium.
Okay, they need tur pressure
to keep a plant upright. It has liquid
and it has potassium to keep it, you
know,
trigger pressure is what they call it.
So if you puncture that plant
and the liquids come out, then the plant
will droop, right?
>> Okay.
>> But plants do not have sodium. They
don't need it because they don't move.
Animals have both potassium and
sodium because they need it for nerve
conduction to be able to think and for
muscle movement to be able to move. So
the difference between plants and
animals.
And by the way, plants do all kinds of
things that are very creative as far as
adjusting to move towards the sun and
all this kind of stuff. But it's a but
it's different than what animals are
able to do. So
phrase, can you phrase that again the
way you phrased it for me?
>> Um potassium it's one of the things that
we both need that it's it's metab it's
like a barometer in in our in our
bodies. So if my understanding from just
sort of like reading Dr. olics, you
know, stuff that high potassium. Um,
it says that something is off in the
metabolic part of the cell. I think is
my is is what it what he said
that if the potassium is too high that
there is something wrong with the
metabolism of that cell. I think maybe
that was the statement that was made.
>> Okay. Where where was he measuring when
he said that? Was he talking inside a
cell or in the blood?
>> I think he was referring to the cell
sort of being as a battery and that it
could short circuit and result in being
paralyzed.
Does that make sense?
>> He may have been talking about a
necropsy where they measured the amount
of potassium within a cell and found it
to be incorrect.
>> Okay?
>> Whereas your typical doctor that's not a
pathologist would have only been
probably looking at blood. they would
been less likely to be looking at
tissue. But since he looked at tissue,
yeah, I mean,
but again, I I think I think the way
first of all, both of those ions
are required with water in certain and
very specific amounts to keep the right
amount of pressure
happening within the cells. So, we all
know that if you drank too much salt
water, your cells would explode and
you'd die because wherever there's
sodium, the water's trying to come in
to balance it out.
>> Gotcha.
>> So, the whole concept of sodium and
potassium is that you only need one
in plants because there's they're not
doing the same things that our nerves
and muscles are doing. But for us, for
the animals, we need both. But here's a
fascinating thing, and I looked this up
a while ago because I wanted to find
out, and I went through Dr. Albre's
books, who Dr. Wallik learned from,
and it I did find it in the literature
that it said that if plants are
deficient in in potassium, they can use
sodium.
So, you can have a plant out somewhere
where there isn't enough potassium, but
there's a lot of sodium, and those
plants are able to utilize that. I
thought that was fascinating myself. But
anyway, so again, the ions have to do
with water movement, making sure you
have the right amount of water and
electrolytes,
mainly sodium, potassium, and you got
magnesium, and you got calcium ionized,
and all that kind of stuff. But yeah, I
mean, I I'll take it. I'll take it. I
mean, I think he he probably that's
probably what he was talking about is
when he' done pathology
on on tissues.
>> The other thing I was sort of fascinated
with, you were talking about the the
cause and the correlation, you know, of
potassium. When you talked about the
babies, the horses, the breastfed, you
know, how they had the higher potassium
and then it reduced, you know, over
those months.
>> Yeah. uh it's it sort of speaks to sort
of how important breastfeeding our
children would be in maintaining some of
those balances in their bodies as well.
Um and then my other
>> exactly
>> and the other question was I was really
sort of fascinated when you were talking
about sort of the muscles
um and that particular correlation. What
I'm wondering is so given all the
science that has been done on these
animals, how do you compare that muscle
thing to people who are like weight
lifters or who who are have a bigger
muscle mass that is normal recognizing
what those balances or imbalances would
have to be in order to sustain their
bodies?
>> That is a great question. Um, another
before I mean when you when you first
start talking about muscle, there are
different muscle fiber types. So you
have people that are that tend that are
lean that seem to be lean and they do
long-distance running and things like
that. You have horses again built that
way too for endurance. And then you also
have these very muscular power builder
like that horse impressive in the in the
horse world. They actually have
completely different muscle fiber types.
So you cannot necessarily take I mean
you can you can improve the shape, size
and strength of any muscle or muscle
cell but it's within certain limits and
those the genetic limits are the muscle
fiber type.
But so when you think about if if if you
go and talk to someone who is a
bodybuilder, an extreme bodybuilder,
you would not believe the amount of food
that they ingest
in order to keep those bodies the way
they are.
>> Yeah. Eggs and tuna.
>> Yeah. I mean, and also Well, so do the
endurance people. But I mean, it's just
it's the more work the body does, the
more nutrients the body needs. And one
of the things I I want to talk about at
some point because it's it's so
important is the whole and and Dr. Wall
has an audio tape on this that's
wonderful. Um, exercise without
supplementation is suicide.
That's the name of it. It's one of his
audio recordings.
And but it's the concept that we're all
talking about. people want if if you
want to be healthy but you're not doing
anything. If you're a library type
person like I am
and I can't I can't do a lot of exercise
because I have so much metal in my neck
and my back. I mean I literally have
have limits on how much quote exercise I
could do. However, I still take care of
all the animals. I still I still move
around. I do very well. And I was, you
know, I'm lucky I'm not in a wheelchair,
which I would, it was predicted I would
be in a in a wheelchair, probably unable
to move by now, and I'm not. So again,
that's from feeding all the the the
parts of the body. But the more exercise
you do, the more nutrients you need to
maintain that. And it's it's fascinating
that people don't understand that
concept.
Um, gym fix, Dr. Wallik has talked about
a lot of these people. Um there were
there were exercise people um
that
they wanted to prove their point so
badly that they refused to take any
supplements because they wanted to prove
that they didn't need supplements and
they died very young.
One of them died running. I think it was
gym effects. This is this is all stuff
in Dr. Wallock's things.
I've also listened to a couple of other
people who talk about this kind of
thing. But, you know, again, if you look
at the some of the earlier people who
did a lot of extreme exercise and sports
and things, if they weren't figuring out
how to supplement,
then they were having a bad outcome.
So, the amount of exercise
relates to the amount of nutrients you
need. And in all these all these
species, all the exercise physiology,
all the charts, when we figure out the
nutrient requirements, it's always
separated by workload. And with horses,
you have a horse that's growing and
racing. They start racing these horses
very young. That's another, you know,
it's an ethical thing. They they do it,
they start training thoroughbreds at a
year and a half. They start doing, you
know, certain events with quarter horses
at two. They do, you know, they run
they're running the quarter horse races
right now with two-year-olds.
>> They do it. They win races. They I mean,
it's part of what they do. But
maybe it'd be better to wait a little
longer.
You know, that's part of the re my first
research project was which was with the
young raceh horses. we were looking at
bone strength and you know bone breaking
and all that. So anyway,
>> you know the reason I asked that
question is um I have several
grandchildren that are fullout athletes.
I mean literally
>> um my granddaughter as you know we put
together a protocol for her and she runs
a mile in 5 minutes and 24 seconds. So
which is almost unheard of. She beats
the division one college rate.
>> So that's amazing. Yeah. Recognizing
that you have all, you know, you feed
the horses different things based on
their muscle mass. How do we learn how
to do that for young girls and boys that
are actually growing, you know, through
puberty at the same time? And we we
carload them. They're on all the plants.
They're on all the all all the, you
know, plant derived minerals on a total
protocol. And then we increase them two
to three times when they're actually
inactivity. It would be really neat to
have, you know, sort of like what you've
done with the animals done for the
people and kids especially.
>> There is a lot of research out there.
>> Okay, great.
>> It is it's out there um on people
because the the thing is where where
will people spend research money and
they will spend it on people. They will
spend it on production animals. Any
money that's gets spent on horses is
just like a gift from somewhere because
you know people don't see the benefit of
spending money on horse research for the
most part. I mean think about it if you
want to learn something and you can have
generations of rats every six months you
know but a horse you got to wait four
years
>> you know what I mean? So there but there
is a lot of research out there about
that. Um, you know, I don't I haven't
looked up a lot of that recently, but I
did I did go to the Ecoin exercise
physiology meetings a week or two ago. I
spent a couple days listening to all
that and it was fascinating. There's a
lady that I didn't even know that has
been at Texas&M and she was
half
animal science and half human
kinesiology, exercise physiology in her
appointment. She's retiring so she's
been there I don't know how long. I had
never met her but she was doing a talk
on mitochondria
and how are we feeding m you know it was
fascinating so but there is a lot of
information out there on human athletes
>> and it's a question of finding it and
applying it and you know a lot of it is
is trial and error too but you'd
probably be surprised at how much is out
there. Again, one of my pet peeves. You
can't necessarily find it all without
paying for journals. But I bet I bet we
could do some research and find out,
you know, some things that would help.
The other thing with, you know, your
women athletes, you got the menstrual
cycle. you better allow for that also or
you know these a lot of these athletes
just become nonfunctional
because they're not getting enough
nutrients and they're using them all up
running and that kind of thing. So for
whatever that's worth.
>> No, thank you very much for your
thoughts. I appreciate it. I will
contact you via your email.
>> Yep. Thanks for the question. Yep.
>> You bet. Byebye.
>> All right. Thank you, Keely. Great,
great questions. And we have Olga
commenting saying, "Just like dogs, some
are very lean
um and extremely strong."
And Kathy says, "Extremely interesting
information and presentation. Thank you
very much for sharing your research, Dr.
Judy." And I want to say thank you as
well as this is this is well
>> as a country kid raised with horses.
>> Yeah.
>> You know I didn't get as deep into it as
my little brother did
>> but man when you go researching you dive
in deep and it just shows your passion
for nutrition and the species
themselves.
So, thank you for sharing that with us.
>> Thank you. For me, I was with horses.
Oh, I could show you this. I showed you
guys. Um, my sister was with Heritage
Makers
and they got moved into Youngevity and
she's been in there for quite a while,
but she is a wonderful she she does
photography and all that kind of stuff.
So, she made a cup for me. And it's not
going to be easy to see, but that's me
with my science fair project
on horses.
>> Adorable.
>> And then here's my first horse,
Buckskin.
And one more. And here's me walking up
to him. Whoops. My my cousin had uh took
that in black and white.
My first horse. But again, all of you
guys do your do your uh longevity, keep
your photos, and do cool things.
>> Absolutely. Nice plug for Y photo or Y
photos.
>> Yeah. where they do have um that
opportunity to take your photos, put
them into something that is you can hold
on to as memories, whether it's on
canvas, canvas, mugs, um
pads.
>> Yep.
So, lots of great stuff with Youngevity,
which folks, this program is being
sponsored by Daily with Doc, where the
only thing that we offer on our website
is through Youngevity because we believe
in the nutrition for solutions so
strongly. We don't need anything else.
So, thank you again, Dr. Judy Reynolds.
folks. Um, if you have questions, you
want to reach out to her, it's drudy
reynoldsgmail.com.
So, thank you again. If I could get our
co-hosts up on the screen, that would be
fantastic. Dr. Judy, do you have any
closing remarks?
>> Oh, I think I made enough remarks at
this point, but um, if you if you send
it's Dr. R Judy Reynolds@gmail.com
and then put DWD in the uh subject line
on your emails because I get way more
emails than I can even get through and I
don't want to miss it,
>> you know.
>> So, you get a priority
from this program over just about
everything else except catastrophes
among the family and you know, stuff
like that. So,
>> awesome. Well, everybody smile.
>> Smile, Dr. Judy.
And thank you everybody who is here live
with us in our live Zoom as we are here
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday from 12 to 1
Pacific, 1 to 2 mountain, 2 to 3
central, 3 to 4 Eastern. and use your
favorite browser to find out what time
zone it is in your time zone so that you
can join us live as well by going to
zoom.dwithdoc.com.
You do have to be logged in with a valid
Zoom account and register and then
you'll be able to come in the next time.
So get back with the person that shared
this program with you folks. Let them
know what you thought as Youngevity does
offer nutrition for animals as well. And
we'll talk more about that on another
episode. So thank you, thank you, thank
you to everyone that you see on the
screen. Dr. Judy being our keynote
speaker today.
Thank you again. you.
>> We have Albert joining us from South
Africa as our gatekeeper. Thank you,
Albert. We have my executive
production manager, Ruth Allen.
um as she's she and Sherry are both kind
of doing double duties as they're
keeping an eye on things out on the
different platforms in the chat here,
making sure that if there's any
questions, comments, I get to see them
so that I can read them here on the show
as well. and um just all these people I
hold near and dear to my heart and those
that are not with us. We keep you in our
thoughts as I know that you are here in
spirit. And thank you to each of our
guests and those that made comments and
came on with questions. That's what
helps us
help you and everyone else that's not
able to ask the questions, but I know
somebody's thinking that as well. Again,
my name is Becca Dukes. I don't know if
I said that in the beginning. I'm a
certified naturopathic practitioner and
certified holistic health coach. And it
is my honor, privilege, and passion to
help you as an individual realize how
empowered you are. and what you put in
your mouth and have in your environment
really does make a difference on your
health
in the short term and the long term. So
folks, thank you so much for joining us
here on Daily with Doc and Becca. And
again, if you're watching us on any any
other platforms,
like, share, and especially subscribe.
Let us know where you're joining us
from. If you have any questions, you can
always email, and this is in general,
not necessarily directly to Dr. Judy,
but you can still get those questions
into us. We'll get them to drud. And
that's questions
dailywithdoc.com.
Now, if you want to get with a certified
holistic health coach, you're not
working with somebody already, we do
have a call team standing by at
855-9493377.
Again, that's 855-9493377.
So until tomorrow when we have farm
suspend back with us,
have a wonderful day and don't forget
how empowered and special you are. You
divinely created
and the body can do amazing things when
you give it what it needs. Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.